[Music]
I feel like a lot of people have been
talk about the fireman romances and
Callie and I have had many conversations
about the Fire Emblem romance firing
three houses romance I'll take it away
yeah what I do this is this is your
topic it's bitter really annoying me
I've been seeing a lot of articles about
the the romances and the you know like
this and that about the lack of queer
romances and I understand like obviously
I think if you're going to you know have
a bunch of characters it makes sense for
some of them to be here it's like III
want work representation of course but I
think it's a it's it's not a good
argument because the game doesn't really
have romances it only has the hint of
romances and so I tweeted about this a
little bit I think if you're gonna have
that hint of marriage you either have
every character be available like every
character be by essentially right or you
have some characters that are dedicated
gay characters but they by room has a
couple of queer options that are also
available to the opposite gender or just
like not do them just not have any more
answers especially like the context of
firing room 3 houses you're a teacher
it felt you're a teacher and like it
felt so I don't say an afterthought but
it just felt kind of tacked on so how
does it work actually so yeah I mean so
there's been such a conversation about
this and it's not even it's it's like
out of the probably 300 scenes in that
game there's like 10 that have to do
with romance and they're so awkward it's
yes so the way it works is the reason
people are talking about it at all is
because in previous Fire Emblem games
have you reached S rank that was like a
romance level a support level right I
was gonna ask for sex right was gonna
say sex rank you I got you
you don't want to say that I will um so
I think coming off of previous fireman
games specifically awakening at fates
you look at that and you say okay I can
only get S rank with these girls as the
female professor which means those are
the queer girls and like yes I at the
when I started playing the game I was a
little disappointed because I was like
ah you know like I'm
have any I played as the blue Lions
there weren't any the only queer option
the blue lions for girls is Mercedes
she's like a
oniisan figure very matronly and I was
like no not gonna know so and so I was
initially kind of disappointed so I get
the disappointment but when you get to
the end of the game basically and this
isn't even a spoiler because like the
it's such a minor thing there are so
many other like rich story beats in this
game you basically choose somebody
there's one guy that's asks you if you
could maybe marry someone who to me and
you pick from a list and then you get
one scene one scene from that and it's
not even it's just kind of this like who
wouldn't we got married
ah it's like the the mean that's like
what if we were both girls and we kissed
in éclairs or whatever it's like that
and then at the end of the game you have
an option to pick from a list of people
in your house who are options to your
character and then you get another one
scene okay so you know it's not romance
yeah it's not like persona levels or
previous Fire Emblem games and I think I
imagine all the comparisons to persona 5
probably also didn't do it any favors -
I think a lot anywhere expecting like oh
it's a persona game and there's it's
it's it's an anime persona get like
persona style game there's got to be
romances especially coming off Fire
Emblem the other fireman games you'd
expect like there'd be some awakening is
so romance awakening and fates as you
said mostly like birth right but this is
it's it's pretty absent and thankfully
it is because I like I always thought
that stuff was like fun in older fireman
games like it was fun matchmaking and
especially in Awakening how you'd match
make and then date and then time-travel
[ __ ] would happen and then they'd
have a kid all of a sudden that was in
your army too and that was always fun
but the actual like romance part was
really bad like the it was just like all
right they paired up they had a
conversation like
you weren't really in it for I don't
know to see their relationship it was
just like I want a new character and I
like them together yeah right the thing
that bothers me and normally I don't do
this normally I don't I'm not like
gatekeeping like this but all of the
Arctic like all of this the discussion
I've seen on the queer romances and fire
them are coming from people who haven't
finished the game and I know it's a long
game and I get it and normally I don't
do this but like this it it's really
misrepresenting what's in this game hmm
when you haven't finished it yet and you
look at the thing you look at a menu it
says s-rank and you make a conclusion
which is I did that while I was playing
but I played it before I had an embargo
so I didn't say anything and then I
finished the game and I was like oh
never mind um so I've just been really
frustrated I think the game is better
for not having romance I do it would be
fun to matchmake the students I'm really
glad I'm not having extensive romances
with my students even though there is a
time skip like that's weird good not
it's nice a little bit of it some of
them are pretty old though
like some of the students like dead away
like coffee your age plus seven twenty
four so are you like the same age sure
that your your ages ambiguous yeah but
they I remember the beginning they like
oh you're like around our age okay no
not the concern for me it sure sure it's
the power dynamic but yeah no no I 100%
agree yeah I I think I think the game
could have done away with ester entirely
or had s rank level conversations that
weren't romantic with characters but I
as it stands it's just like such a non
thing yeah I mean in general and games
I've always found it kind of weird how
like romance is supposed to be the ideal
like top reward achievements for for
like hang like it on the one hand like
with Mass Effect I like that I think
they got better about it over time but I
always I like I go back and forth on it
where like I I hated that there were
some characters that if you didn't
pursue the romance option their dialogue
was like severely limited you'd only
have like three you have like had like
their dialogue would be like cut in half
in terms of like actually getting to
about the more as a character and I
think they got like better about that
over time where they would like have
more routes for like you know platonic
relationship versus romance but just the
idea of a game being like your reward
for hanging out with this person is a
romance is like it doesn't have to be
that all the time yeah like nothing
about Fire Emblem to me feels like I
need to romance these characters so I
rather just get to know them and be like
good friends for them yeah I mean some
of them are flirty and that that largely
depends on their personality you can
have tea parties which is the most anime
thing in the game it's also very awkward
- you can have tea parties with anybody
like like the bestest be likes you take
Felix and he's like why am I here yeah I
just like I'd rather they had had queer
relationships among the students like if
like because there's some students that
flirt with each other right and there's
like little like scenes with them yeah
if they the thing that bothers me is
when relationship options are by by
defaults but the characters are only are
only gay if they're with you you know I
mean like if you're free if you're a
female character and the female romance
options are only queer just because
they're dating you and I don't think
that's like good writing but I think the
other thing is this is an excuse but
this is a Japanese game and I think
Japanese games are going to be a little
bit behind where we might want them to
be in terms of these things not the
Japanese Japan is like super not
progressive but especially with like
male male relationships you that's a
dicey thing I think it can be
complicated and I think to like
criticize it outright especially when
it's not even a thing it's just like
making too much better
[Music]